[Musique]
enfin les enfants bonsoir les
hauts-fonds buts ou les châles ok bien
pressé je suis pressé car je vais
travailler je descends écrire le
merveilleux livre des mémoires de
nounours et croyez-moi patron chez
cornichons avec le calme de la campagne
je travaillerai dix fois mieux
qu'ailleurs et hop hop hop hop hop hop
hop hop hop hop hop hop hop
j'espère qu'il aura bientôt fini
d'écrire ces lignes howie au calme et
bien installée
boussois horaires amis votre table de
travail vous attend regarde honda tout
préparé
à la tuque rayée merci à lons l'ours au
travail haha je sens mon l'inspira selon
qui ces jeunes nous ont fait pas de
bruit
je me retire son la pointe de messam au
[Musique]
bond ou laitage voyons puis caché
derrière un énorme glisseront jaunâtre
on dit le ciel total orange
tient tant c'est une allemande qui
change mais bien que twitter à cette
heure-ci c'est un rossignol des clowns
sont en effet
très bien écouter les lions avaient faim
soudain un tigre sur j ai dit
[Rires]
non c'est vous qui me fait me tromper le
silence ne parlait plus voilà pour
l'état
oui soudain un tigre sont j'y
tiens une vache mais elle rentra les
tables alors elle appelle son petit veau
écoute
[Musique]
ballon que ce que j'écris soudain tigre
sur j ai dit me
belleau trouvaient les enfants arrêtez
de faire du bruit
bon alors un tigre sur j ai dit
tu es mal à écouter ce que vous me
faites pas écrire le ciel était à
l'orage les lions avaient faim soudain
tigre sur j ai dit ben
ça vous fait rire et bien moi je ne
trouve pas ça drôle du tout alors amis
il avance ses livres bok nam
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je ne suis plus du tout ce coach du ni
ce que j'écris avec tout ce bruit chers
amis vous feriez mieux de remettre votre
travail à demain oh oui le nours remet
revient dans manhattan échelles assume
au lit mais tu as tout entendre allons
bien prendre un peu l'air
bonne nuit amis et que la nuit les
étoiles et le clair de lune vous inspire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors nounours tu as bien travaillé
nos patrons ça n'avance pas fort ça ira
mieux demain demain ça ira mieux en
route bonnier des enfants allez vite
vous couchez les feux de brousse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
e
enfin
non
[Musique]